and now who connects four it's black
this time with the connect four the mean
girls well they're always in the middle
of support it's it's the different pawn
structures the different variants of
chess i think maybe that should be a
variant
yeah i know you know a fusion of connect
four and chat yeah maybe you could get
like some extra time the prettier like
pawn uh structure you have yeah magnus
laughing as well maybe just at the pawn
structure
expect him to play this move just so
that if we okay very strong pawn in my
opinion yeah and uh magnus just asking
questions of raj above um rajabov very
sharp very quick to see that pawn
capture the wind of the pawn magnus
taking his hand off the mouse meanwhile
maybe we can show as well how and why
that was such a big blunder uh while
magnus carlsen thinks uh no sorry while
timor rajab thinks because in this
position um we do see that white is a
pawn up and this is where magnus he's
just brought his rook to the side okay
we'll see some moves but white took this
pawn and this is what magnus has missed
it looks like black has covered this
this pawn twice but if the black bishop
had taken and the white rook slides
across and because of this pin this
bishop is doomed and this was what
magnus had not spotted instead if we go
back to the position lots and lots of
moves after the pawn stepped forward we
saw
the white knight step back then
wow okay let's go back to the players
because magnus just resigns
okay wow so sudden the world champion
doesn't even fight on wow it's over